Now, let's go ahead and switch to vs code and let's do a brief.
tutorial in discrete mathematics
So these are the topics that we are going to cover. First of
all, this is vs code. It is
a IDE.
Which stands for integrated development environment you
can download this from Microsoft?
but basically what I have here in the left and the
left panel
Is a markdown file which allows me
to, you know create?
So first of all in the left, we have I have
a markdown file on the right panel. I have a preview
of the markdown file. So this
is a render.
Of what I have on the left. So basically I can use
three Ampersand signs to create a level three
heading I can use dashes to
create a bullet point and then I can use the
latex. This is called lady. You see these dollar signs.
They allow me to write or type out mathematical symbols.
So it's a much neater than
writing it on.
a Blackboard
But yeah, basically what we have
on the left is a markdown file
you if you look at the video description, you'll see
where they find this.
and on the right
we have the the preview.
that's actually just switch to the
preview itself again. This will be a very short
tutorial if you want to.
Go into all of these in more depth check out
the video description.
So we'll cover sets functions some properties
propositional calculus relations, and then I
will switch to show you graphs visually.
That would be more efficient way to understand graphs.
Okay. Now there are many simple other symbols in
discrete mathematics.
I'm only going to show you a handful of
these.
Okay, so these are the symbols.
The names of these symbols and I'll show you how to
be used.
So I said as what I said
as a mathematical structure.
That is it as a collection of objects to which.
some rules apply
now if you look here.
we have a set a
and you can see that it's pretty straightforward to.
Define a set of mathematics.
And once again you have your curly brackets, you have your
objects. In this case. We have numbers and then you assign to
it a variable here. We have a now sets
of course can also contain other objects.
So they don't have to be numbers. So for example,
here we have
five six which are integers and then we have
the set a
or a set containing the set a
the function f which is defined down here and we
have some Vector B, whatever that is.
so just like in python or other program languages where
you can
declare an array
and put mixed data types in the
array you can do the same thing in mathematics.
Okay, this is not.
A doing anything particular you particularly useful.
It's just
to show you
The program equivalent of this mathematical expression up
here or the mathematical Expressions up here.
So doing this in Python would look something like this you would declare you would
declare a dictionary.
Excuse me, it would declare a set.
Okay.
And if you want to define the function f you
would have defined keyword followed by the name f the parameter
and the return.
value of the function
if you look here in the programming.
Block the function f Returns the
length of some set where some set is
a parameter.
So if you want to call this function.
You would say F. So something like this, right?
Something like this. If you want to call the function you
would do it like so
f
And pass a The set a as an argument.
And this will return the length. So how many items do we
have in this set a well? We have five.
We get 5 that will be the return value.
Once again in Python, the Ampersand is
a comet. So if we call this function you will get 5 as
the return value.
Well, if you look up here, this is the mathematical equivalent.
We have these two vertical bars. We call this the cardinality of
the set.
So big word, but all really means is the number of elements in
that set. So this is by the
way map notation. We would talk about function in a second. But this
is map notation. Basically we have map which Maps
We have a map F which Maps the set a or
the elements in the set a to the cardinality of
that set.
Okay, so it's a map that
it's a
functions are maps by the way functions are types of maps a function
will take the set a and
Map it to its cardinality so you will get the set.
and
the number of items in that set
and then we have functions.
I just alluded this I just alluded to this
but we have two ways to defining functions. You can
either Define them as Maps or as
equations. So let me show you both up here.
We have a function sum a python function sum
which takes as
Argument number a number so these
are the parameters of the function.
And then in here we have in the scope of the
function. We have another variable num C which is the sum of well
these two numbers.
Which is then returned by the function?
so if you want to Define this function in
mathematics, we would say let
Sum, what's the name of the function and a colon?
And what the map?
Some will do.
Is it will take you from two real
numbers to one real number right? Because
that's what we said this the sum function does.
So let's sum.
Map from the real number system
the real number system be a function defined as well.
As you see it has expressed here.
It is a function that takes two variables.
and then it will be equivalent to
the sum of those two valuables which we can also refer to
as
anonymously
now if you want to call the function, let's and print
its value. We can call the sum function.
and
pass this sum function as the argument of the print function.
And this is what we call a mathematics that compositional functions. So
how will python processes? Well, it will
first evaluate some
so you will get the number five and that past that to
the print function.
And let's not forget the rules with parentheses when
whenever we have multiple parentheses involved. You always go
from the inside and work your way out.
So since we have two and three, this is the innermost pair
of parentheses. We will evaluate that first and then
go out they could this the equivalent of
this.
in program in excuse me, mathematics would be to
Well compose a function as follow so we have one function called print
and sum and we indicate that with this circle this
big circle.
and then the arguments
right after that.
So a composition of function this is
equivalent. This expression is equivalent to that. Once again, this
is math not programming, okay.
So these two are equivalent.
And here's an example of defining a function with control statement. So here
we have a function check exists which takes the parameters element
and this set so basically we'll see
if this element existence set and return true and false. Otherwise,
And if you want to create a function with a control statement in
mathematics, we do it this way.
This is called a piecewise symbol. This is a piecewise
function.
Say I will return true if the element is in a this
do you see this?
A character that looks like a e flip through
flipped around. Well, that's we this is
pronounced in so element in a so of the
element is an a then we will turn return true.
Otherwise if the element is not an a
return false.
All right.
Let's move on to sets now. Let's look at the
union and intersection operations.
Say we have two sets a and b.
So the set a is the numbers 1 through 5 and B is
6 to 10.
What if we want to combine these two sets or if
you want to take the unit of these two sets. We're in Python. We have the
method called Union right a union B and what we will
get if we are run this code.
Is the set.
containing all 10 values and
let me just modify this because
This is not an assignment.
rather
I meant to say that this is a comment.
Okay.
So I did not mean to put that equal sign. I just made to say that if you
call this function you will get that set.
All right.
How do you perform a union in mathematics? Well,
you have the same two sets a and b.
I just had to correct that this I
might put B here so we have two sets A
and B to take the union of the two sets we have.
We have this symbol this you looking simple we
have this you looking symbol.
And I just made sure to put the curly bracket. So that's
what the union does. Okay.
And then the intersection what is the intersection with the intersection
of?
The intersection of two sets is when you
create a third set.
That contains the elements common to both sets. If you
see here in Python, if you want to run this you would
have an empty set.
Why because well there is no number that is
common to both of these sets.
Which is why this is empty.
and Mathematics if you want to take the intersection
of two sets, you have the same looking symbol,
but it's
turned upside down
Okay, so that's the intersection of A and B. And since
they have no elements in common we get
same a set with no elements in it.
And by the way in math when we have a empty set, there's also
called a null set.
Which can be also represented with a this zero
looking character with a line that goes through it.
That's a good proposition to calculus.
So this is a very simple FNL statement.
We have two variables p and Q both assigned
to true and V equals to false.
Well what happens if we print p and Q in Python will
get you right because
the and operator
will check to see if both statements are true.
And if you do p and v
since both conditions have to be true and one of these conditions is actually
false V. That is we'll get
false.
but we know that we can also have
complex truth statement so here what we're doing is
We have q and view.
as one
Statement and P as another statement. So what we want to do is evaluate
these two statements. Well again what the
rules of parentheses we have to evaluate the innermost parentheses and
then go up. So how do we evaluate this first? We
evaluate Q in view?
Well Q is true V is false.
Only both of them have to be true one of them isn't so
this would be false. And since this is false and this
is true.
And they're both supposed to be true. We're also going to get fast.
Okay.
And then we have the not operator.
So if this statement is true, then the
exclamation will give you the opposite the complement. That's
the word we want to use the complement of this expression.
So since this is true, we apply the complement and
we get the opposite which is false.
And this is the equivalent of the above in mathematics.
Okay.
So this is the and operator.
The or operator and then of course when you have multiple statements
you want to make sure you put in the parentheses.
And up down here. We have the complement. So we have this kind of L looking
character. That's the complement. So this is the equivalent
of that up here.
All right.
now relations
this is this is a
very small
example of this is just to make clear.
What a relation is.
Just check the video description to find
out find them more.
complete
tutorial
but let me give you one quick example of where relations are
applicable in mapreduce.
if you are a data scientist or data engineer
understanding relations set relations
can really help you with applications like mapreduce.
So what is a relation a relation is a set?
that
Associates to other sets
or you can lie. If you if you want you can go with definition up that
I put here that a relation explains the social Association show
of two of more sets. So let's say we have the relation r
Which is a set with tuples.
If you look at the set you quickly understand what's
going on in here, right? We have a city.
And the country in which it is located city in the country
city in the country, right? So that's the relationship.
So this relation is the association of two other sets
to set a and set B where set a is the set
of cities and B is the city of is the set of
countries.
so
if we want to say that.
Chicago and the United States go together. We
say Chicago is all related to the
US.
Which means that these two go together and they have
to be ordered. So for example, when we say Chicago are you
as that means we will get a tuple where you
put Chicago as the first element in the US as
a second element again, the notation is very simple.
But being able to read relations.
Where you see them and being able to recognize them where
you see them is going to make a huge difference.
in your
journey to learning by the way graphs.
So the prerequisite for understanding graph Theory which
is a huge and very important.
Branch, in fact, it has a branch of its own graph Theory.
Is understanding relations.
Now I don't have space here to create a visual
representation of a graph.
So let me show you a PDF.
Right. So here's a PDF there I found for
you on the web and let me make sure we can see the
text.
So this is what I mean when I say you want to be able to
read mathematics to make
sense of Concepts in either computer science or data science. So a
graph is defined as a space
and a space is a set of
points.
Or a space is a set of sets.
So G is the graph and it contains
V, which is a set of vertices and E which is
a set of edges.
Okay, so if you look here down here, this is
the graph your vertices are V1 V2
V4 V3 and V5.
All right.
And of course, we have a set of
edges which they have not labeled in here, but the edges of course
are these lines?
That go to the next.
To go from that go from one vertex to the other.
one way to represent
graphs are with matrices. This is what we call
an adjacency Matrix it basically tells you.
Which Vector goes to which Vector through
what edges and how many times so this is
let's say the column for
the first.
vertex
It tells you that it has one Edge.
Going to itself. You see here. Let me zoom in.
It has one Edge going to itself then it
has three edges going to the second vertex. That's
One Edge second Edge third Edge, so three edges
going to vertex two.
It has zero edges going to avert extreme.
If we look carefully we can see that it hasn't it that vertex one
has no direct edges to V3. So that's why
we can see 0
and then if you come to Vertex 4
it says that we have three edges. Do we have three edges? Yes, we
do. We have one two, three. Okay, we
don't count that one because that's just from V4
to V4.
And then again, we have no direct edges to V5. So we get
zero in here. And if you go continue this way
for the other vertices, you will have complete the adjacent to Matrix. Now,
what's nice about this is that you can use
linear algebra techniques or Matrix techniques to
evaluate.
The structure and the paths of
a graph and this has well, I
will leave it to your imaginations.
to see you know
I will leave it to manage to consider the applications that this
can have but this is very
It has many applications now. There
is not a lot of
There's just there's just not enough time for me to cover all
of these. So if you want to learn.
A lot more about the topics that we have discussed here
today, especially graphs and their applications
check out the video description. This is a short
tutorial. There's a more elaborate tutorial furthermore. There's
an entire course on everything we talked about. So let
me just switch now to the slides
again to talk about the course.
If you want to learn more about the course a mathematics
and programming.
Visit this website. The link is also in the video description and let
me show you the page.
So you want to scroll down to the upcoming courses and Mathematics
and programming?
click on learn more
and
what you want to do is check out the lesson plan
if you can scroll down here read all
this information.
And then click on the lesson plan to see
the structure of this course.
Remember that we have a slack Channel where?
Everyone will be participating and where you can ask questions.
So if you do have any questions just scroll down click on
the link to the slack Channel. We can also find the
main page.
All right. Click on the joints like
to ask any questions you have about this about this course,
okay.
But that's it for this session. I want to thank you for watching.
I look forward to seeing you in the next one until next
time. Take care. Bye.